y'a un mec qui m'a dit que j'étais
mignonne mignonne moi ok je vois que ça
choque personne
non ça tombe bien ça tombe bien j'ai mon
dictionnaire mignonne mignonne terme de
tendresse à destination d'un enfant de
moins de 8 ans exemple qu'elle est
mignonne cette petite fille
donc quand le mec il dit de moi que je
suis mignonne c'est pas dans son
ensemble
morgan mais qu'est ce que t'es mignon
non non non non non c'est plutôt dans le
sens promenons nous dans les bois
pendant que les lois une pâquerette que
ce soit bien clair messieurs lorsque
vous dites qu'une femme est mignonne
ça revient à dire qu'un homme est gentil
gentil ça va ça vous parle
c'est bien gentil bah non c'est nul moi
j'en ai marre d'être mignonne et comme
ça là et comme ça lâche mignonne et
comme ça la chine mignonne et comme ça
ridicule
moi je suis allé voir mes amis parce que
ce n'était pas la première fois qu'on
l'a dit que je suis mignonne et dont je
leur ai demandé est mignonne d'accord
mais je peux pas être autre chose
drôle oui super bowl ouais quoi
empathique 6,6 empathique
oh punaise ou fait chez les gars c'est
parce que je suis en fauteuil que chez
mignonne c'est parce que je suis en
fauteuil que je peux pas être autre
chose que nora la petite exploratrice en
bouffer trop de dettes après un accident
de voiture
moi aujourd'hui
j'aimerais que les gens me voient tels
que je suis en manque
moi j'aimerais qu'on me dise morgan
thébaux nas morgan tessala morgan t
perspicace aimé mieux j'ai mais
j'aimerais qu'on me dise mais morgane
m'étais vraiment qu'une grosse [ __ ] avec
tes de bibi et prends moi la tête et
labit
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant pourtant je pensais avoir
trouvé la solution devenir un objet
convoité par les hommes
une bagnole je deviens les pneus moi
j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on se retourne
sur mon cul carénage concombre luc le
pare chocs comme palpe les herbes à
comment remplir sa jauge comme des
montants non l'emporté quand tu es mon
top me
et comme termine par un petit coup de
polish est pourquoi je pourrais pas me
faire démonter moi j'ai envie de finir
en pièces détachées messieurs de quoi
avez vous peur ici là tout ça là ça
marche
bon ok c'est peut-être pas le bon mot
mais là ça roule
monsieur c'est quoi votre prénom basse
et françois françois il faut deux que je
vous avoue que qui tue complètement
flashé sur vous depuis que je suis garé
sur scène vous seriez pas un peu mécano
par hasard ah mais ça c'est génial un
morceau c'est génial il est mécano
maintenant vous avez pas entendu mais il
est mécano et ça c'est génial parce
qu'en ce moment mais j'aurai besoin
d'une révision complète en plus vous
avez l'air trop haut mais vous avez
l'air trop trop gentil
on vous a pas dit on voudrait pas
prévenu maintenant c'est une heure
trente de conférences sur la sexualité
des personnes handicapées
honnêtement vous seriez venue alors que
un quart d'heure à parler humour c'est
quand même plus vendeur on est d'accord
l'humour pour faire passer des messages
c'est beau c'est fort
on utilise tous les jours pour moi
l'humour c'est un saint suppositoire de
message à diffuser
on le sent à peine passé non c'est vrai
on sent on le sent à peine passé mais le
principe actif peut agir tranquillement
pour moi l'humour c'est cse mais comme
ça les des graines dans vos têtes et
puis et puis vous vous rentrez chez vous
et puis la graine et germes
tranquillement doucement donc moi là je
viens de semer la graine de la question
de la sexualité des personnes
handicapées
ouais cette phrase elle est longue ouais
et on utilise tous l'humour on a bien vu
on utilise l'humour pour aborder des
sujets lors des tedx on utilise l'humour
pour séduire pour impressionner et puis
aussi vous aussi je suis sûr que 99,9
pour cent de la salade déjà utilisé
l'humour pour faire passer un message
puis 10 99,9 il ya tout le temps à
rebours qui qui qui rigole a jamais
aucune blague et vous avez déjà transmis
un message je sais pas à votre meilleure
amie pour lui dire que sa nouvelle
petite copine vous l'appréciez pas trop
enfin pas du tout en fait ou bien votre
collègue qui arrivent souvent en retard
paul paul tam entre elles l heure
d'hiver toute l'année la seule
différence entre vous et moi c'est que
l'humour j'en ai fait mon métier parce
qu'au fond on a tous des choses à dire
d'ailleurs j'ai une annonce à faire je
suis chiante
enfin j'ai pas toujours été drôle parce
que l'humour pour moi ça a été un moyen
de résilience
alors je m'explique
la résilience c'est cette capacité à
encaisser les traumatismes et à se
reconstruire
bon je suis pas spécialiste boris
cyrulnik pourrez vous en parlez bien
mieux que moi mais à la base la
résilience c'est un principe de physique
un matelas à mémoire de forme ou un
coussin mémoire de forme de la marque
qui commence par temps et qui finit par
pure par exemple tiens ça à tout le
monde moi c'est résilient voilà je
m'assois dessus
il subit un traumatisme gros traumatisme
et quand je suis plus dessus
eh bien il se remet à sa forme initiale
est bas dans la vie c'est pareil dans la
vie dont la vie ça va bien ça va bien
jusqu'à ce que bîmes traumatisme épreuve
on tombe et résilience on se relève et
puis de nouveau tout va mieux
et bim a maintenant un nouveau
traumatisme on tombe et on se relève et
moi je peux vous dire mes neveux qu'une
collection des preuves
ouah j'en ai oui parce que je suis pas
né je suis pas né handicapé je suis pas
né en fauteuil il n'y a personne qui a
dit à ma mère à l'isi il y pousser
pousser
bravo vous avez une petite fille a
poussé poussé le fauteuil arrive le foie
la haye à une roue qui commence qui ça
coince non non non tout allait bien et à
10 ans on m'a dit que j'aurais une vie
très courte
bîmes je tombe je me relève
et puis se sont trompés et à 16 ans j'ai
développé des douleurs très importante
et on me dit que de toute façon je
devrais vivre l'intégralité de ma vie
avec merde les autres il s'était trompé
bîmes je tombe
je me relève et et arrive 2008-2008
ouais c'est ça j'ai 19 ans bîmes
je retombe je m'assois là j'étais sur le
cul au sens propre comme au sens figuré
le cul vissé sur un fauteuil
mais ça c'était pas une épreuve non
j'avais autre chose à penser à l'époque
j'avais mes examens à passer mes
diplômes à passer mon entrée à l'école
d'ingénieurs à préparer donc ce n'était
pas une épreuve
et puis le temps passe et puis j'entends
des choses sublimes à répétition madame
enfin voyons mais vous vous doutez bien
qu'entre votre candidature et n'importe
lequel de ces fichiers là notre choix
est déjà fait morgane annonce nous deux
ça va ça va pas pouvoir le faire quand
je te regarde
bah je vois tout ce que je peux pas
faire ça c'est antoine chez qui j'ai
réveillé des instincts d' escalade à
chaque fois qu'ils me voyaient c'est
quoi le problème
si ça c'est le fauteuil il fauteuil ses
accessoires et là c'est devenu un
problème
et moi je me souviens quand j'étais ado
je pense que comme la plupart des ados
on aime bien que le centre de
l'attention la gt r
regardez-moi réécouter moi j'ai quelque
chose à vous dire
bon je sais pas ce que j'ai à vous dire
mais j'ai quelque chose à vous dire
et puis à partir de l'épreuve du
fauteuil j'étais plutôt ne me regardez
pas maintenant ne me regardez pas pas
comme ça et ne m'écoutez pas pas si
c'est comme ça et là là c'est un
traumatisme
parce que j'ai su j'ai compris que on
vit au travers des yeux des gens qui
nous regardent
je suis tombé et je me suis assise et
j'ai oublié la suite je suis tombé je me
suis rassis et qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
après ah bah oui le temps il a passé je
me suis inscrite en thèse et tout ça est
et puis j'ai pris du recul je suis
devenu quelqu'un je suis devenu
célibataire je suis devenu je suis
devenu quelqu'un sans perspective
d'emploi apparemment mais de plus en
plus drôle parce que parce que j'ai pris
beaucoup de recul sur moi parce que j'ai
appris à vivre à traves avoir à travers
les yeux des gens qui me regardent et ça
c'est très important se met à la place
d'autrui
et paradoxe total plus plus le temps
passe et plus je devenais drôle pour mes
amis mes soeurs et mes parents parce que
pour le reste du monde
plus je devenais chiante oui parce que
j'étais chiante et et voilà et j'ai
encore oublié ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est terrible qu'est ce que tu me
dis ah oui et là je me suis mise au
théâtre merci maman est là je me suis
mise au théâtre
je me suis mise au théâtre pour
extérioriser tout ça pour extérioriser
ma colère j'avais besoin de devenir
souple de devenir un matelas mémoire de
forme
voilà et puis première représentation
décembre 2014
théâtre d'improvisation avec mes
collègues mais alors c'est le coup de
foudre
mais c'est pas le coup de foudre roi et
puis après plus rien non c'était le
couteau doit mais sans toi je meurs
c'était pas possible de faire sans je
suis sur scène je suis je suis quelqu'un
je suis moi et j'ai mis trois en trois
ans à à mettre dans la balance devenir
intermittents du spectacle ou autoroute
devenir docteur en génétique
bon je vous dis pas qui pesait le plus
dans le game et et je me suis donné
trois ans et pendant ces trois ans j'ai
vu j'ai vu le regard des gens qui
changent est avec moi sur scène j'ai vu
j'ai vu les mentalités changer et je me
suis dit mais mais par le rire on peut
faire tellement de choses et si je
pouvais dire tout ce que j'ai à dire si
je pouvais dire tout ce que j'ai vécu et
tout ce que je vis encore mais ça serait
tellement fort tellement puissant
tellement puissant regardez moi
écoutez moi c'est ce que je me disais hé
j'étais enfin redevenu l'ado
complètement relou et puis et puis
égocentrique et narcissique
ouais enfin j'avais gagné j'étais
redevenu mois et 3 ans voilà c'est ce
que je me tais je m'étais donné je suis
devenu altruiste je suis devenu ouverte
j'ai intelligente et croire et j'ai eu x
fois en mois font la vie en ce que je
suis foi dans le pouvoir de la scène et
du rire est au bout de trois ans je n'en
pouvais plus je je brûlais c'était
viscérale et fallait que je monte sur
scène et là je me suis dit mais morgan
passe à l'action
je suis passe à l'action j'ai passé une
audition et j'ai été admise dans une
école de théâtre sur paris
on est en juin 2017 et et voilà je suis
admise je commence à écrire des sketches
bon au début les massages c'était comme
ça moi mon premier sketch je les écris
sur mon chien d'assistance avec le
message que il regroupait beaucoup de
gens auprès de moi mais c'était pas les
beaux gosses que je voulais non c'était
plutôt les petites mémés qui me
parlaient de leur chien qui qui il faut
dire que y'a pas mieux que kiki comme
chien on est d'accord et et après j'ai
plus j'apprenais plus + josette et j'ai
osé parler de la sexualité des personnes
handicapées avec le sketch mignonne que
vous avez vu et bientôt vous pourrez
m'entendre parler d'autres sujets d'un
événement essentiellement qui qui je
pense est arrivé à à plusieurs d'entre
vous une semaine après l'audition cette
femme et auditions jeu je perds ma soeur
la grande soeur non là je respire je
perds ma grande soeur est pas dans le
sens [ __ ] qu'est-ce que j'en ai fait
n'en faut faire le chemin arrière alors
qu'elle était là j'étais là qui est
sorti les poubelles non j'ai perdu ma
soeur
et vous savez quoi
jamais été aussi drôle parce que j'écris
sur moi j'écris sur ce que je connais
j'écris sur ce qui me fait vibrer
j'écris sur sur ce que j'expérimente et
que je suis pas la seule à expérimenter
j'écris sur ce qui me fait rire et qui
est partagé merci et et moi je l'attends
je l'attends le prochain trauma jeu
parce que j'attends les épreuves
j'ai envie j'ai envie que le prochain
trauma il arrivait que je lise et aimé
tu vois ce que je souhaitais fut tu sais
ce que je suis devenu mais moi je suis
devenu un matelas mémoire de forme manga
ouai
voilà les épreuves
écoutez moi regardez moi j'ai quelque
chose à vous dire
et là je vous regarde tous et je ne sais
pas quelles sont vos épreuves donc je
vous écoute
qu'est ce que vous avez à me dire
[Applaudissements]